in 2003 clinching the divisional series
for the eventual World Series champion
Florida Marlins is a 14-time all-star
behind the plate baseball hall-of-famer
here care of our friends at Bank of
America Pudge Rodriguez good to see you
sir what is that memory for you
he's very good one of my best moments in
my career just to be able to get that
last I'll be able to hold that baseball
in my glove
even though JD's know hit me really
really hard but it just just a matter of
the team effort that with a whole year
starting spring training and to be able
to get there to get to that moment and
beat the Giants in 2003 which is as
everybody knows here that in the giant
was a team to beat you know that great
team and they have that real pitching
they have and-and-and the mauling just
be able to eliminate the Giants in fight
game and move on and and when you know
the series in the cabin went with with
the giant with the Yankees and when the
Boise was a was a premium about that
play right there you know it's one of my
best place in my yeah the Giants went to
the World Series here before lost the
Angels and then you guys eliminated them
the next year but what what is that what
is that feeling like we're you know
somebody's about to try and blow you up
and separate you from the baseball well
what is that sensation like in that play
it was I knew that that play is gonna
happen
I knew that JT is no he's gonna is gonna
come and try to knock me down and and
you know and you know just you know get
the baseball away from me but the great
the great thing about the play was at
the base it was the left and me you and
me you when you see the level you see
the runner with the corner you iron and
that to me was a was a big advantage for
me is easy it's different when you when
you see the trow from right-field and
left
but I know you know Conine you know have
a great one huh
you know when Hebrew saving the club and
through it a perfect one hop to me and I
was able to secure a name my club but
basically I just might owing ham inside
of the globe and and just let JT JT hit
me and that's what that was a play so
who who's the best player you played
with best player play with that play
with so many as you did once but I'm
asking for one cuz you know we in the
media we we don't want many we just
teammates you know teammates I've played
with one Gonzalez one was all it was a
great players you know by made of Julio
Franco team polymer played three years
we know long ride him and that was that
like catching him grape unbelievable you
know just I know they're like I know the
Pedro Martinez right Roy you know guy
that throws 90% 90% 95% of the time fast
balls and and and I like that you know I
like aggressive pitchers guys it has the
that I know they have great fastball and
not afraid to throw but the but they
starting pitchers that I have that year
when I came up you know I have Nolan
Kevin Brown Kenny Rogers
you know Jose Guzman all those guys are
such a great picture that made my job a
lot easier
were you behind home plate when Robert
mature went out I was behind the plate
okay I was behind the plate and it was
pretty intense it was a pretty intense
fight I know that you know that's gonna
happen you knew he was gonna charge them
well you know he's everything happens
there the series before my way in
Chicago
mm-hm they story that was a story you
know that I don't remember what happened
the series before then the Nolan and and
Robin been through that get at it a
little bit and and you know a week later
they come you know they played
three-game series
in Arlington and no longer I avoid
pitching him and that's what the acident
happened but it was intense it was there
it was a lot of a lot of big big guys in
there in that big group of people
fighting but but he was kind of like
interesting to be in the fight did you
not hold Robin back I mean your jawline
I just trying to hold them that well cuz
you or you just knew that the old man
noogies were coming charge it to fast
having had a chance to go the Robin
Ventura getting to the run spot Nolan
and you know it wasn't fun man oh man oh
man
who did you square off in that one did
you square off with anybody in that
fight no not really I know this is this
is a true story but I was having a gene
I was having a surgery in my cheekbone
48 I was before I was playing with a big
you know patch right here in my left
side huh we came from Kansas City and
he'll be broke hit me with the bat you
know those kind of double swing that in
doubt re-balance and hit me my in my
face and Brooke my my job mm-hmm and I
was playing 40 48 hours later so I was
kind of little very hitting where do you
want to stay I was a little scary when
that fight was going on cuz you don't
know you can see it right there you see
that white right next to yeah there it
is
we're looking at a photo a still
photograph of it right there and then in
terms of you know one of the craziest
games of all time and o3 after you
secured that ball to get to the NLCS you
were in Wrigley Field correct was really
for the Bartman game right famous
Bartman game what was that like
from you
perspective when that ball goes down the
left field line and to me to me that you
know everybody criticizing the the poor
fan and I don't think that was his fault
I mean I know it was a it was a
catchable lie ball obviously yes but
that's part of the game you know
everybody can every a lot of fans can
reach for for a ball and sometimes you
know fans are catchers sometimes players
catch the ball but I think that was in
the play that we eliminate the the cups
that year I think that was the the the
the play after the ground I think that
was that was the reason that they lost
but there wouldn't have been anybody on
first right I mean did you yes I mean
and I'm not doing this - I mean look
Bartman's life has been heard enough
okay I got it but he's got his ring now
apparently but did you know a guy's not
sit in the dugout right there and think
okay this is our our chance
oh absolutely you know when you giving
an extra eye out to a team you're always
gonna score some runs and that's what I
that's what I teach today I I work for
the Rangers and I always always telling
kids in Manly do not give a team a next
route because if you do you're gonna get
damages you're gonna score a run and we
got a break obviously we have a break
there like everybody else
yeah it could it could have happens to
you know to the cups too in that
situation you know the luck went our way
there you know Bartman you know put his
club and and and and boy says our Lord
didn't catch the ball and then the rest
was history a couple more minutes left
with Pudge Rodriguez here in the Rich
Eisen show before we talk about B of a
your son's playing now huh Derek
Rodriguez thank you now I know it's not
spelled the same way but is it named
after is he named his name is he won he
won yes okay but it's Derek for Jeter is
it no
no no no really that was a desk that was
his mother's his mother ideate with a
middle name in in the middle okay yeah
but his first name is he won yeah he's
doing well RIT is pitching good I'm very
happy proud of what he's doing you know
he's uh he's only been for four years
pitching he was you know he was an
outfielder with the twins and yeah but
he always have a grown man and from and
the and the improvement that he's been
doing from four years that sunau the
mechanic you know they stay back there
you know they stay over the top and and
pitched oh he's he's doing great plus he
has some great coaches you know the
first couple of years with the twins you
know so he's now with a great group of
guys in the Giants organization you know
when you see Johnny Cueto Bumgarner
Samardzija all those guys are talking to
him a lot and he's doing good but but
the one thing that they did do well the
his present is is he looks like he's
been in the big league for 14 years and
he's not afraid to throw strikes he's
falling one he average you know a
hundred pitches per star and throws like
60 strike every single start you know
they he throws yeah
and so when you throw Rick you throw a
lot of strikes again
wanna and you know I could say this
based on based on the way I look the
hair comes from the mother side right
yes see mine I mean here we go we do
from the eyebrows
pretty much from the eyebrows up okay B
of a I use the mobile banking I do that
all the time he's got that on my phone I
use it all the nights phenomenal he's
good in a pawn it off with the Bank of
America as you know there's you know the
issue of Bank of Major League Baseball
and I'm I'm very happy to partner with
them and this week off a game and in the
app I use it too is very easy
yeah very fast and and especially in
today's the way we live life that's what
we need you know something quick that we
can get and and and it's been working
very good and and especially here you
know your star game with all the
activities going on is the best app to
use and looking forward later just to be
also in the fan fest I'm gonna be the
you know sign an autograph talking to
people and meeting quickly people so
looking forward to be there a little
later yeah I mean you know we're in
between innings you could transfer funds
you could pay bills right there it's
really I use the mobile app all the time
hey good to see you sir thank you do
this again let's do it again spud you
got it the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience